the Joe Rogan experience do you remember
that early Ford cars the the early Ford
cars were made with hemp all of his
fenders and everything were made with
happen is a video of him taking a hammer
and bang a sledge and banging it off the
fenders and it shows you the insane
durability that hemp fibers have have
you ever seen that
yeah but he never they never made it
into production right I think that was a
wartime shortage R&D effort same thing
with stainless you ever seen any of the
prototype a couple of them still exist
but yeah so Ford I think it was the 37
Tudor it was a 61 maybe t-bird was the
newest and there was a third one that
the entire bodies made out of stainless
and there's so bad GM did one during
World War two during the metal shortage
time entire plexiglas Buick sedan in it
sold in auction recently and I
plexiglass slightly so if I can tempted
yeah so the entire body is clear like
you see through the doors you see the
regulator's everything it is so badass
and it sold for what didn't seem like an
absurd it was like 180 200 grand
Wow so actually can you google that
image it's a plexiglass prototype Buick
I think it was hopefully we'll find it
super super nifty Wow
I know that was the company Lotus lotus
developed a hemp fiber car they did like
an anniversary one of their what is a St
George's there is to the left
Wow one more over yeah look at that
that's insane like are you kidding me no
[ __ ] cool green oaken apparently it
cracked and proved not to be viable so
never made a [ __ ] just as like a
sculpture to have you in your
and cave the things so bad yeah really
cool like there's all the as that safety
bracing on the door structural bracing
on the doors
I also for a while like I wanted to do
there was a Dow Corning and somebody
else there was a big consortium that was
doing a bio derivative molded plastic
concepts so like four years City trash
cans and stuff and the durability and
the life cycles and everything were epic
and I was thinking for all like how
badass would it be invest all the money
in the platform of the vehicular
engineering and then make the body
literally by design almost disposable so
when it's at the end of its lifecycle it
literally could turn into mulch and go
on the ground totally neutral right or
more interesting ly more liberating it
for a consumer and a designer like let's
say that same platform you had you could
have like a dune buggy style like okay
I'm gonna take it out to the desert and
we're gonna go elk hunting or whatever
the hell you're gonna do that weekend
right
anyone like a buggy truggy style or you
know we're doing construction at the
house and we're gonna use it for you
know hauling soil or whatever so you
could have like modular bodies and
different applications used on the same
platform but all bio derivative
materials I think that'd be super cool
well I've always wondered why someone
didn't but besides Lotus didn't make
another hemp bodied car because you know
Corvettes still uses Plexiglas or
fiberglass for all their cars but hemp
is far superior it is me and you it's
another one of those things like why
isn't ya moving forward someone make
maybe you should do it maybe we should
make like a 69 Corvette but make all the
panel's redo them in hemp fiber hate to
say it but you're going up against the
petrochemical industry and I do not want
to be that for you sure I mean all the
chemical interest in plastics you would
if you're just rebuilding something do
you really think that it would be that
big of a deal like they would come after
you if like if you took all the body
panels off and by the way would probably
so much stronger if you watch the video
of see we can find that video of Henry
Ford banging the hammer off of reading
about it right now it might not have
been what was like he lied he didn't
live the video that putting out the
video live okay
is what this article says what does it
say the angry historian wrote a big blog
about it dug through it that seems to be
a prototype as he was saying and it was
probably plastic it might have been some
hemp in there but it wasn't he some
finder maybe it wasn't even 50% him well
how does he know that he did begging
with all its all the places that this
that the information came from forties
and all the places that they were
talking about making angry historians
pretty balls out serious when statement
he does his homework interesting I had a
friend who had a stalk of hemp you know
one of those the base of a hemp tree on
his desk and he's like picked that up
and I picked it up and I guess it looks
like like a piece of oak like it looks
like it looks like a real eye can we
feel it it's really hard but it's really
light it's the weirdest plant like if I
don't have you are held a piece of hemp
hemp stalk it's like an alien plant it
doesn't seem to make any sense yeah and
its properties and its structure is so
unique and there's so many benefits to
it for sure yeah I would think I mean
see if you find that Lotus the hemp
Lotus they had it where the front stripe
down the center was clear coat so you
could see the actual hemp fiber in the
in the Lotus but no one's ever done
anything they still make Corvettes out
of plastic I mean still making them out
of fiberglass I would think that that
would be like a real straightforward
approach especially now that hemp is
legalized and you can grow it in the
United States and in most states
I think it's federally illegal yeah I
you know I I for my leather goods like
this jacket is all hemp thread real is
super strong oh yeah it's better than
anything so that stripe down the middle
is all the clear coat natural hemp fiber
so that whole car is made out of hemp
[Applause]